foreign
dear colleagues it is an honor for the
European Parliament to have the
president of Slovakia Susanna chaputova
with us here today Madam president
diazuzana welcome
thank you for your vocal promotion of
the values of equality and diversity
that this house and our Europe holds so
dear
last week's double murder at the heart
of Bratislava is a reminder to us
of the constant need to fight back
against hate and defend our lgbtiq
community President chaputava we know
you also as a firm defender of freedom
of speech
soon we will mark five years
since the murder of Slovak journalist
Jan kuchiak and Martina kushnerova that
shocked us to our core this house Madam
president will always remember Jan and
Martina and you will always find us as
an ally in the defense of values
dear Susanna let me quote your words in
a speech that you gave at the United
Nations General Assembly you said that
solidarity should be our binding
principle not an option and your country
Slovakia has demonstrated what
solidarity means by welcoming more than
half a million Ukrainian refugees since
the onset of War by being at the
Forefront of political and military aid
to Ukraine Slovakia has shown time and
again that it can lead thank you for
your country's leadership at this
critical moment for Europe president
chaputova the floor is yours
come on
president
honorable members
the representatives of the Czech
presidency of the council my fellow
Europeans
it's an honor and privilege to be here
and to address the Beating Heart of the
European Union's democracy here in
Strasbourg
this is a city where the modern concept
of Defending Universal human rights
was translated into concrete
institutions
while serving a broader purpose I see
the European Parliament as one of them
my message today is simple
if we don't start defending democracy it
will cease to exist
the date of my speech here was planned
long ago
I couldn't have expected that the recent
homophobic murder of yurai Van college
and matus Horvath on the streets of
Bratislava would remind us of this
simple truth so painfully
it's hard to put in words the grief felt
in Slovakia cities in the past few days
because I hate decided to kill love
just because the killer couldn't not
accept that love can come in different
forms
this was an assault not just on young
people from the lgbtiq community
it was an attack on everyone in Slovakia
because hate crimes always Target the
very essence of what our society stands
for
I would like to assure you that hatred
doesn't dominate our society
I will come that Slovakia Civil Society
immediately and resolutely condemned
this attack
just yesterday the Slovak Parliament
adopted a resolution strongly condemning
these are terrorist attacks and ensuring
all minorities that they are valuable
members of our society
in its Essence democracy is the rule by
the majority in the interest of all with
a key emphasis on the protection of
minorities
if we are failing in their protection we
are undermining democracy itself
in my view the defense of and protection
of democracy is the core mission of our
generation of political leaders
the task ahead of us is to bring Europe
back into balance
which is shaken by crisis from within
and without a balance between our rights
and our commitments
between our security and our prosperity
which we have partly built through
dependence on those who wish to destroy
our democracy
a balance in which we can have different
opinions but where we are bound by the
values of Freedom solidarity and the
liberal democracy
and now please allow me to switch into
Slovak so even here into European
parliament's chamber one can hear the
beautiful Slovak language
president
Madam president honorable members
the balance that I've mentioned
has been threatened in the past two
years by two major crises
the pandemic and the security crisis
caused by Russia by invading Ukraine
as a European Union we reacted the right
way to both crises in the pandemic the
national closing of borders and the race
who would procure more
face masks were quickly replaced by a
common approach and solidarity we
started to recover our economy
post-pandemic with the help of the
resilience and
recovery facility and solidarity is
shared also beyond our borders we are
today one of the biggest Global donors
of vaccines against correlate 19 and
equally decisively have we reacted to
the war that Vladimir Putin waged on the
24th of February against our Eastern
neighbor let us remember that this war
only intensified on this Gloomy February
morning that Russia waged this war long
before first by disinformation and
propaganda and since 2014 also in
military way with the clear goal to
subjugate Ukraine or to destroy it
we have imposed the most extensive
sanctions as the European Union against
Russia
sanctions that have never been this
extensive against any developed economy
we provide political Financial
humanitarian and most of the countries
including Slovakia also military aids to
Ukraine
very important is the European
perspective that we offer to Ukraine and
I'm convinced that one day it will
culminate in a full-fledged membership
without Aid we have one goal to achieve
peace however peace has to be just
otherwise it would only be a temporary
ceasefire
we have
opened not only our homes but also our
hearts to those who had to flee War
some 800 000 people crossed just the
Slovak Ukrainian border and many of
those remained in our country and I'm
very proud of the solidarity and Aid
that was offered by our citizens
both crises left the Europeans
not only with fear and worries but also
with the experience of a very strong
europe-wide empathy and unity and this
experience shows us that the best way to
overcome any challenges that we face as
Union is our Unity cooperation and
solidarity
ladies and gentlemen our efforts to
restore the balance in Europe does not
do not stop here it is paradoxical that
in a situation where we are
unprecedentedly United against external
challenges we also face very strong
internal pressures they are caused by a
Confluence of several crises but also by
ignoring our vulnerabilities for a long
time if we do not cope with these
European crises we run the risk that
they will grow into a crisis of Europe
millions of how European households and
companies are threatened by skyrocketing
Energy prices today these prices began
to rise even before the war since Russia
has already begun to reduce gas supplies
to Europe already last summer and it
started thus to restore distort the
European energy Market
and threaten our citizens Slovakia which
until recently had 85 percent of its gas
from Russia
managed to reduce its dependency to 33
thanks to diversification however we
never know when a Vladimir Putin stops
any gas supplies for good as a union we
have to address the courses and the
impacts of this crisis the right
Solutions therefore have to be European
common and in solidarity those that will
urgently help all in a difficult
situation all member states and apart
from compensations will allow an
agreement on a common gap on gas prices
we need to decouple the prices of
electricity and gas because even today
countries such as Slovakia are
generating most of his electricity from
low carbon sources pay inadequately high
prices for it and therefore I would like
to ask you to support such Solutions
however apart from the consequences we
have to address the causes that brought
us here never again may we remain on one
supplier as a union and never again May
our economic model and prosperity depend
on fossil fuels alone the commitment to
become a climate neutral continent by
2050 can no longer be delayed or put in
question first and foremost we have to
help those
who are hit the hardest by the energy
crisis but the goal is clear we need to
innovate innovate our development model
in order to use renewable energy sources
to a greater extent and destroy our own
Planet less
we must become Global leader not only in
our climate commitments or Ambitions but
also in implementing them
we will only survive if we restore the
balance between our way of life and the
planet where we live
honorable members
today
we Face a crisis of democratic rules and
their respect each country that joined
the European Union and each country that
wishes to join has to be and has to
remain a liberal democracy
being a member of this club is not an
entitlement it's a privilege
it is not enough to achieve membership
in this club the membership has to be
constantly updated with a clear
understanding and respect of common
values values such as the rule of law
division of power
Independence of the Judiciary freedom of
the media or protection of minorities
if these cornerstones on which our
community is built are under attack we
have to have to act to protect them I
want to emphasize that we do not like
the rules as much as we like the
consistency in enforcing them if our
measures are not decisive problems will
grow and those who violate the values of
the European Union will encourage and
Inspire others the very notion of
liberal democracy
is being disinterpreted misunderstood
questioned and attacked by the Extremes
in many of our countries even though
there is not a single model of liberal
democracy I am certain that illiberal
illiberal democracy are two incompatible
Notions
honorable members our Democratic rules
are today abused to destroy democracy
itself
freedom of speech is one of the most
important Democratic rights we need to
protect it but it's not without
limitations
how could it happen that we let freedom
of speech escalate to verbal crimes
how could we elevate it many times to an
absolute right this is not Democratic
this is stupid the freedom of speech
cannot be a cover to spread intolerance
lies and disinformation
nowhere is this problem more acute than
in social networks the radicalized
teenager that killed two young men last
week and injured a third-person
industries of Bratislava was greatly
inspired on social media and before the
murder he published a long pamphlet on
Social Network full of hatred against
various minorities
this murder did happen in Slovakia but
the risk of such crimes concerns all of
us
we witness
a growing aggression against minorities
and the growing right-wing extremism in
many parts of Europe
the worsening of the socioeconomic
situation only enhances the in
confidence of radicals we need to be
aware that any attack based on hatred is
an attack against the very values of the
European Union and that include equality
tolerance and respect of Human Rights
it seems that we take a similarly naive
approach to Social Network as we take to
other technological innovations without
due caution we use the benefits without
knowledge and vigilance of their
potential and obvious negative
consequences we use social networks
without being fully aware as a society
how their algorithms May harm us how
they deepen the polarization and enhance
filter bubbles
to believe the truth to live the truth
and to defend the truth is the motto of
one of the founders of the modern Slovak
Nation General Milan rastislav stefanik
in public space it has to apply even
when it seems that it would be more
efficient to shout loudly regardless of
the quality of truthfulness of the
statement instead of listening to each
other engaging in dialogue and caring
for facts let us not let democracy
perish on the naivety of Democrats on
the naive belief that Democratic rights
and freedoms will only be used and never
abused let us not forget that every
right is at the same time an expression
of responsibility and vice versa
and if we do not protect democracy it
may happen that we will be the last
generation to experience it its
protection is the main task of our
generation of political leaders
therefore we have to take appropriate
steps in this area at National level it
is good that the European Parliament
adopted the Digital Services act and I
also welcome the European democracy
action plan what is illegal offline has
to be illegal online
[Applause]
however we need to also do more at the
global level the business model of
social platforms is based on the use of
the lowest human emotions and impulses
social platforms are not just operators
of the proverbial information pipelines
because their profit is directly
proportional to how much hatred how much
aggression lies and this information
flows through these Pipelines
they must therefore bear reasonable
responsibility for the content that is
published on them
Madam president honorable members
the challenges I'm talking about today
make the European Union more fragile
than we may realize and admit the
economic security and energy crisis the
ongoing fragmentation of our societies
and the pressure of illegal migration
these are all bring grounds for
extremism in many member countries of
the Union One election cycle is enough
today and in the Parliamentary benches
even here in this house
in your seats there can be a majority
that does not want to build Europe but
destroy it
therefore may we must not be naive we
must not be lacks and defensive but in
the contrary we must be persistent
courageous and self-confident in the
defense of our common values despite the
inevitability of solving many crises and
perhaps precisely because of it we must
not forget that the performance of
Politics as such should be based on very
clear values that is on the value
um that we have to defend as politician
politicians if we believe and stay true
to these principles this will not be a
show of weakness but the contrary the
first president of Czechoslovakia Thomas
garigma sarek already said 100 years ago
that democracy is not only a political
system but first and foremost is a moral
system let's all think about it when
carrying out our mandate which is a
responsibility and an obligation towards
our citizens if we perceive democracy in
this sense I am sure that we will manage
the crisis we are facing today and thus
fulfill our mission to be the Guardians
and Protectors of democracy of European
values and of the balance thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
we're finished
thank you very much that concludes
the formal
sitting
and we're there by resume
I was sitting with the votes
I will give one
minute for you to
find your seats and place your voting
cards